You look like your apartment looks like the saddest place on earth. You're like there with a hoodie. The hoodie is for echo cancellation. I figure if I put the hoodie up, it captures more of the sound. The hoodie is for echo cancellation. A line that will go down as one of the greats in the annals of podcasting history. Welcome to ADSP The Podcast, episode 25, recorded on May 12, 2021. My name is Connor. And today with my co-host, Bryce, we revisit the problem, maximum consecutive ones, and discover a missing algorithm.
你看上去你的公寓简直是地球上最悲惨的地方。你就像那样穿着连帽衫。连帽衫是为了消除回声。我想如果我戴上连帽衫，它能捕捉到更多的声音。连帽衫是为了消除回声。这句话将作为播客史上最伟大的名言之一被载入史册。欢迎收听 ADSP 播客第 25 期，录制于 2021 年 5 月 12 日。我是 Connor。今天，我和我的联合主持人 Bryce 将重温“最大连续 1”问题，并发现一个缺失的算法。
So here's the thing. So now, so let's take a moment to explain my place to you. I have a bed. I have a desk. And I have an office chair. And so the echo is awful. I don't have any other chairs. So right now I have carted my office chair from my office, through the kitchen, through the living area, through my bedroom into the closet. And my you're in a closet right now. Yeah, it's sort of it's like it's like an open closet. So it's a it's a closet without like doors in the midst of a hallway. So it's only really got it's not like a closed drawer thing that's a part of the closet and then i pull out the second drawer which is my socks and boxer drawer and then that's where i put the mic and it actually works like perfectly does this apartment have windows because i have not seen evidence that this apartment have you not have you not seen my view bro no i have not seen your view yeah okay that's a pretty good view it's a pretty good view oh that's a pretty good view
事情是这样的。现在，让我们花点时间向你介绍一下我的住处。我有一张床，一张书桌，还有一把办公椅。所以回声非常严重。我没有其他椅子了。所以现在我把办公椅从办公室搬出来，穿过厨房，穿过起居区，穿过卧室，搬进了壁橱里。你现在在壁橱里？是的，这就像是一个开放式的壁橱。它是一个位于走廊中间的没有门的壁橱。它并不是一个封闭的抽屉，它是壁橱的一部分，然后我拉出第二个抽屉，那是放袜子和内裤的抽屉，我就把麦克风放在那里，效果竟然出奇地好。这间公寓有窗户吗？因为我没看到这间公寓有窗户的迹象。你没看到我的视野吗，兄弟？不，我没看到你的视野。好吧，视野相当不错，视野相当不错，哦，视野相当不错。
that's a pretty good so you're in downtown now i'm gonna have a better view when i'm in new york uh you know why it's yeah because you're bright you know why i'm gonna have a better view in new york because you're price because i'll be looking at new york city not toronto i mean take that canadians here's what i'll say about new york i visited once twice i can't recall it smells like garbage you get used to that you get used to that it gives a character the smell gives a character do you want to know why it smells like garbage bryce well usually because there's a lot of garbage because there's like the same way that in the winter time there's big piles of snow on the corners
视野相当不错，所以你现在在市中心。等我到了纽约，我会拥有更好的视野。你知道为什么吗？因为你很聪明。你知道为什么我在纽约会有更好的视野吗？因为你是 Bryce。因为我看到的是纽约市，而不是多伦多。我是说，加拿大人听着，关于纽约，我想说的是，我访问过一两次，记不清了。那里闻起来像垃圾。你会习惯的，你会习惯的。这赋予了它个性，气味赋予了它个性。你想知道为什么它闻起来像垃圾吗，Bryce？嗯，通常是因为垃圾很多，就像冬天街角堆满积雪一样。
of street in toronto there are big piles of garbage bro you don't, you don't even, you don't even understand in New York between like Christmas and so, so the, the, um, the, the sanitation workers in New York has a very excellent union. Um, and, and from like, I think it's like from Christmas to January, there's like no trash pickup, like none. And so during this period of time, some quite substantial piles accumulate. Yeah, but the smell gives the city character. It's a problem because I like to run specifically outside, and I can't be inhaling garbage.
在多伦多，街角有大堆的垃圾。兄弟，你根本不明白，在纽约，圣诞节到……嗯，纽约的环卫工人有一个非常强大的工会。嗯，从圣诞节到一月，好像根本没有垃圾回收，一点都没有。所以在这段时间里，会堆积起相当可观的垃圾堆。是的，但这种气味赋予了城市个性。这是一个问题，因为我喜欢在户外跑步，我不能吸入垃圾味。
It's not that bad. It's not that bad. You're making it sound like it smells everywhere. It doesn't smell everywhere. Central Park was quite nice. And if you're most of the places along the sort of what in Vancouver is called the Stanley Park, the seawall, that's what they call it. You can go for like a walk and it's a pathway that sort of surrounds the park and it's right next to the ocean. That sort of happens in New York. Anyways, enough about New York.
没那么糟糕，没那么糟糕。你把它说得好像到处都是臭味一样。并不是到处都臭。中央公园相当不错。如果你去温哥华所谓的斯坦利公园、海堤，他们就是这么叫的。你可以去散步，那是一条环绕公园的小路，就在海边。纽约也有类似的地方。总之，关于纽约就说这么多。
Anyways, I got this dope setup and my apartment's too big that I would have to furnish it too much. So I'm pretty sure I'm getting my sister, my older sister's moving to Calgary. And so I'm acquiring one coach, one shelf, and two patio chairs. Can you please just appoint your sisters to decorate your place? Just for my benefit. I've only met one-third of your sisters, but I'm confident that they're all classy people who can take care of this problem and it'll make me sleep better at night. I'm definitely going to outsource it to individuals. It's not going to be my responsibility.
总之，我有了这个很棒的配置，但我的公寓太大了，我得添置很多家具。所以我很确定我要找我姐姐，我大姐要搬去卡尔加里了。所以我打算接收一张沙发、一个架子和两把露台椅。你能请你的姐妹们来装饰你的住处吗？就当是为了我。我只见过你三分之一的姐妹，但我相信她们都是有品位的人，能解决这个问题，这会让我晚上睡得更好。我肯定会把这事外包给别人。这不是我的责任。
But this doesn't explain. You asked about the webcam. So I have an external webcam, which I do not. I take my chair. I take my laptop. But the webcam stays on the desk. I can bring the webcam next time, but it's a very – Right now I'm looking at Connor,
但这并不能解释。你问到了网络摄像头。我有一个外置摄像头，但我没带。我带了椅子，带了笔记本电脑。但摄像头留在桌子上了。下次我可以带上摄像头，但现在——我现在正看着 Connor。
and Connor looks like the protagonist in a movie about like a rogue hacker. He's like super blurry, and he's got his hoodie on, and he's in like a white void. The hoodie is for echo cancellation. I figure if I put the hoodie up it captures more of the sound the hoodie is for echo cancellation a line that will go down is one of the greats in the annals of podcasting history oh man it's um yeah i i feel it's i wish we had been putting these on youtube because uh the the delta from my last place where i was right next to windows and had great lighting and
Connor 看起来像是一部关于流氓黑客电影里的主角。他非常模糊，戴着连帽衫，身处一片白色的虚无之中。连帽衫是为了消除回声。我想如果我戴上连帽衫，它能捕捉到更多的声音。连帽衫是为了消除回声。这句话将作为播客史上最伟大的名言之一被载入史册。天哪，我真希望我们能把这些放到 YouTube 上，因为和我上一个住处相比，我当时就在窗户旁边，光线很好，身后还有一株植物，色彩丰富，而现在我只是黑暗中的一个影子。好吧，我想我们应该开始做正事了，对吧？是的，这些都会放进播客里。那全是精华。现在我们要开始讨论“最大连续 1”了。
had a plant behind me lots of color and now i'm just a shadow in the dark. Yeah. All right. So I guess we should probably do our thing, right? Yeah. This is all going in the podcast. That was all gold. And now we will start talking about Mac's consecutive ones.
（注：原文此处有重复，已按逻辑合并）
Yeah, I think I solved it. This is our second time for transparency because at ADSP the podcast, we're all about transparency. This is our second time for transparency because at ADSP, the podcast, we're all about transparency. This is the second time. We recorded this on Mother's Day, but it was a good recording, but I was a bit confused, and I was staring at the code that Bryce was sharing with me, and I figured our listeners are going to be super lost. So we said this is— No, this is the third time, Connor.
是的，我想我解决了。为了透明起见，这是我们第二次录制，因为在 ADSP 播客，我们追求透明。这是第二次。我们在母亲节录制了这一期，那是一次很好的录制，但我有点困惑，我盯着 Bryce 分享给我的代码，我想我们的听众会完全听不懂。所以我们说这是——不，这是第三次，Connor。
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah. That's true. That's true. Like three weeks—no, maybe four weeks before that. time, Connor. Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah. That's true. That's true. Like three weeks. No, maybe four weeks before that. So, okay. All right. We should take a step back.
哦，对，对，对。那是真的。那是真的。大概三周——不，也许是四周前。那是真的。那是真的。大概三周。不，也许是四周前。好吧，好吧。我们应该退一步。
We should take a step back. Nah, let's take two steps forward. First, Connor, why don't you explain the max consecutive ones? Right, yeah. Let's do a mini recap. So this is probably, what, the second or third time at least that this has come up in our podcast. It was a problem that I solved or showed the solution to using parallel thrust algorithms in my GTC talk that happened in April. And very briefly to recap, you're given a sequence of ones and zeros.
我们应该退一步。不，让我们前进两步。首先，Connor，你为什么不解释一下“最大连续 1”呢？好的，没问题。让我们做一个小回顾。这大概是我们播客中至少第二次或第三次提到这个问题了。这是我在四月份的 GTC 演讲中，使用并行 Thrust 算法解决或展示过的问题。简单回顾一下，你得到一个由 1 和 0 组成的序列。
And the problem is to simply return the length of the longest contiguous sequence of ones. So for example, if your sequence is 1100111, you have basically two sequences of ones, which are of length two and three. So the answer to that problem would be three. And in my talk, the way that I if you know, for the full solution, I guess we'll link to our previous episode where we first talked about this. And I'll also link to our previous episode where we first talked about this, and I'll also link to the GTC talk. It's basically using an algorithm called thrust reduced by key, which first segments the sequence into contiguous elements of equal value.
问题很简单，就是返回最长连续 1 的长度。例如，如果你的序列是 1100111，你基本上有两个 1 的序列，长度分别为 2 和 3。所以这个问题的答案是 3。在我的演讲中，如果你想要完整的解决方案，我想我们会链接到我们第一次讨论这个问题的上一期节目。我也会链接到 GTC 的演讲。它基本上是使用一种叫做“按键归约”（reduce by key）的算法，首先将序列分割成值相等的连续元素。
So you're going to end up with three sequences, two ones, two zeros, and three ones. And then by default, it does a plus reduction. So you're going to end up with the values two, zero, and three. All the zeros always sum to zero. And then once you have those three values, you just take a max element. And at the end of that episode, or sort of halfway through, I think we were discussing, or you were discussing, or I guess we were both discussing. I said, I think this can be done in a single pass.
所以你最终会得到三个序列：两个 1，两个 0，三个 1。然后默认情况下，它会进行加法归约。所以你最终会得到值 2、0 和 3。所有的 0 相加总是 0。一旦你有了这三个值，你只需要取最大元素即可。在那一期的结尾，或者说中途，我想我们正在讨论，或者你在讨论，或者我想我们都在讨论。我说，我想这可以在单次遍历中完成。
Correct. A more efficient implementation existed. Now, we should clarify that. First, Connor asked me, what algorithm would you use to implement this? And I gave the wrong, I gave the answer that was not what he had in mind, not what he showed in his CDC talk. And then I was like, ah, but I think it can be done in a single pass and of course not not wanting not being able to live with the shame of having failed to accurately identify the algorithm in my own library that did this an algorithm which two years prior i had taught connor about
没错。存在一种更高效的实现方式。现在，我们应该澄清一下。首先，Connor 问我，你会用什么算法来实现这个？我给出了错误的答案，不是他想的那种，也不是他在 GTC 演讲中展示的那种。然后我说，啊，但我认为这可以在单次遍历中完成。当然，无法忍受未能准确识别我自己库中实现该算法的羞耻感——这是一个两年前我就教过 Connor 的算法。
i was like i must go solve this and so in in in your defense you did at an earlier date and time come to me without even me asking you and said hey you can solve this problem or a similar problem using reduce by key and at the time i didn't know about it and i said was that when we met yeah that was probably when we met yeah that was literally january of uh 20 2019 when i think i first gave the algorithm intuition talk at the the meetup which we're going to be attending in like an hour um to do a sequence okay so after this embarrassing incident where i failed to correctly identify the algorithm that i had taught connor about you know, when we first met, that is an algorithm in my own library. I was like, all right, forget the rest of my Saturday.
我说我必须去解决它。所以，为你辩护一下，你确实在更早的时候，甚至没等我问，就主动来找我说：“嘿，你可以用 reduce by key 来解决这个问题或类似的问题。”当时我不知道这个算法，我说那是我们见面的时候吗？是的，那可能就是我们见面的时候。那确实是 2019 年 1 月，当时我第一次在聚会上讲解算法直觉，我们大约一小时后就要去参加那个聚会了……所以，在这次尴尬的事件之后，我没能正确识别我教过 Connor 的算法，你知道，当我们第一次见面时，那是我自己库里的算法。我说，好吧，剩下的周六我不管了。
I'm going to go implement this. And I went and I wrote it, wrote a single pass implementation of this algorithm in terms of a reduction. And then. And then I got on the Twitter DMs and I told Connor, come on, man, we got to go record another episode right now. I'm so excited. And we recorded, and that was some great podcast material that's never going to see the light of day. I should add, you said, let's record a 10-minute addendum. And I think I was in the middle of something, and I was like, I'm sort of busy. And you were like, just, it'll be 10 minutes. 55 minutes of addendum later.
我要去实现它。我写了一个该算法的单次遍历实现，用归约的方式。然后我上了 Twitter 私信告诉 Connor，来吧，伙计，我们现在得去录制另一期节目了。我太兴奋了。我们录制了，那是一些永远不会见天日的精彩播客素材。我应该补充一点，你说：“让我们录制一个 10 分钟的附录。”我想我当时正忙着什么事，我说：“我有点忙。”你说：“就 10 分钟。”结果录了 55 分钟的附录。
And the conclusion of that addendum was, because I was still sort of writing the code as I was talking with Connor, the conclusion was, oh, wait, no, there was a bug in my thing. So then I was like, all right, well, cancel that whole 55 minutes. And then I think later that week, I was doing yoga with my mom. I do yoga with my mother twice a week. And inspiration hit me. I realized how I could solve this problem. And I went and I coded up a little bit, but something distracted me. So I never mentioned it to Connor again. But then last week, I was speaking with my friend, Tony Lewis. And we were talking about what belongs in the C++ standard library, my C++ Now keynote. But then at the end of our conversation, he mentioned this podcast episode and this problem. And he said, oh, hey, I think I found a solution to it. And he showed me his solution. And his solution was in terms of a scan.
那个附录的结论是——因为我在和 Connor 交谈时还在写代码——结论是：“哦，等等，不，我的代码里有个 bug。”所以我说：“好吧，取消那整个 55 分钟。”后来那周我跟我妈做瑜伽。我每周跟我妈做两次瑜伽。灵感击中了我。我意识到如何解决这个问题了。我写了一点代码，但有些事分散了我的注意力。所以我再也没跟 Connor 提过。但上周，我和我的朋友 Tony Lewis 交谈。我们讨论了什么应该进入 C++ 标准库，也就是我的 C++ Now 主题演讲。但在谈话结束时，他提到了这期播客和这个问题。他说：“哦，嘿，我想我找到了一个解决方案。”他向我展示了他的方案。他的方案是基于扫描（scan）的。
And we'll explain more about that in a little bit. But I looked at his solution. I was like, aha, yes, this is not only do you have the right answer, but this reminds me that Connor and I have to do another attempt at solving this problem in a single pass. And then on Mother's Day, we recorded that episode. And then afterwards, we were like, well, Connor was like, yeah, the way that we explained that was too confusing. So then now attempt number three is today.
我们稍后会详细解释。但我看了他的方案，我说：“啊哈，是的，这不仅是正确的答案，而且提醒我，Connor 和我必须再尝试一次在单次遍历中解决这个问题。”然后在母亲节，我们录制了那期节目。事后我们觉得，Connor 说：“是的，我们解释的方式太令人困惑了。”所以现在是第三次尝试。
And also shout out to all the moms. Happy Mother's Day belatedly. Hi, mom. Thank you for doing yoga with me. She's a yoga instructor slash lawyer. And she gives me free yoga classes on Zoom twice a week, which is absolutely wonderful. And it's a great way to connect with your mother, especially during a pandemic. And tell me, Connor, what did you send your mother from Mother's Day?
另外，向所有的母亲们致敬。迟到的母亲节快乐。嗨，妈妈。谢谢你和我一起做瑜伽。她是瑜伽教练兼律师。她每周在 Zoom 上给我上两次免费的瑜伽课，这绝对太棒了。这是与母亲联系的好方法，尤其是在疫情期间。告诉我，Connor，你母亲节送了你妈妈什么？
Why are you bringing this up? Because now I got to cut this out. Our family is not a big gift family. I did a three-hour Zoom call with my three sisters. My dad popped in for a little bit. I was confused. My parents don't listen to this, but I was confused on why we didn't invite. I felt so bad for my dad because it was a three-hour call,
你为什么要提这个？因为现在我得把这段剪掉。我们家不是那种互送大礼的家庭。我和我的三个姐妹进行了三个小时的 Zoom 通话。我爸爸也露面了一会儿。我很困惑。我父母不听这个，但我很困惑为什么我们没邀请他。我为我爸爸感到难过，因为那是一个三小时的通话。
and I think he showed up at like the hour-and-a-half mark, and I was like, poor dad. He's just off over in like a different room, jealous of her mom. I sent my mother her favorite wine, two bottles of it, a cheese pairing, and I may have sent other stuff. I don't remember. And then I sent my grandmother chocolates, flowers, probably some other stuff because I am a good son. Anyways, anyways, let's move on to the algorithm. Okay. Anyways, let's move on to the algorithm. Okay, so the problem we're trying to solve is we've got an input sequence,
我想他在一个半小时的时候才出现，我说：“可怜的爸爸。”他只是在另一个房间里，嫉妒妈妈。我给我妈妈寄了她最喜欢的葡萄酒，两瓶，还有配酒的奶酪，我可能还寄了其他东西。我不记得了。然后我给祖母寄了巧克力、鲜花，可能还有其他东西，因为我是个好儿子。总之，总之，让我们继续讨论算法。好的，总之，让我们继续讨论算法。好的，我们要解决的问题是，我们有一个输入序列，
and we want to count the longest run of consecutive ones. So we want a single pass parallel algorithm. So whenever we've got a problem that amounts to counting, this usually boils down to being a reduction. So something like a count or like a stood count or a max element, etc. You're looking to look through all of the data and find one answer. So the intuition is, okay, maybe we can write this as a single pass parallel reduction. So almost any time that you're parallelizing a problem, the first thing that you do is you split up the input into sub-ranges. And I think that's where we should start in explaining this. So let's imagine we've got our input sequence and
我们想计算最长的连续 1。所以我们需要一个单次遍历的并行算法。每当我们遇到一个涉及计数的问题时，这通常归结为归约。比如计数（count）、std::count 或 max_element 等。你需要在所有数据中查找并找到一个答案。所以直觉是，好吧，也许我们可以把它写成一个单次遍历的并行归约。所以几乎任何时候你并行化一个问题，你做的第一件事就是把输入分成子范围。我想这就是我们应该开始解释的地方。所以让我们想象我们有输入序列，
we split it up into sections. And then we assign some thread to work with each section. Well, let's think about naively what we want each thread to do. Well, we're looking for the longest consecutive run in the entire sequence. So sort of the first thing that seems sensible is each thread should figure out within its subsequence what's the longest sequence in that region, right? Does that make sense? Okay. but that's not actually good enough because what if the longest run happened to span across two of these regions that like thread zero has you know 10 elements and thread one has 10 elements and the longest run spans from the last five elements of thread zero to the first five elements of thread one. Well, now somehow we need to find that sequence,
我们把它分成几个部分。然后我们分配一个线程来处理每个部分。好吧，让我们天真地想一下我们希望每个线程做什么。好吧，我们是在寻找整个序列中最长的连续运行。所以第一件看起来合理的事情是，每个线程应该找出在它的子序列中，那个区域最长的序列是什么，对吧？这有道理吗？好的。但这实际上还不够，因为如果最长的运行恰好跨越了这两个区域怎么办？比如线程 0 有 10 个元素，线程 1 有 10 个元素，最长的运行跨越了线程 0 的最后 5 个元素和线程 1 的前 5 个元素。好吧，现在我们需要以某种方式找到那个序列，
and that means that we have to propagate information from left to right, from thread zero to thread one. So how do we do that? Well, the approach that I took and the approach that Tony Lewis took is to create a summary for each region. We'll talk about how that gets created in a minute, but for each sort of chunk of the input, we're going to create a summary. And that summary needs to have three key pieces of information. The first piece of information is what is the longest run in that section. We already said that. That's pretty straightforward. But it also needs to identify what is on the left-hand boundary
这意味着我们必须从左到右，从线程 0 到线程 1 传播信息。那么我们该怎么做呢？好吧，我采取的方法和 Tony Lewis 采取的方法是为每个区域创建一个摘要。我们稍后会讨论它是如何创建的，但对于输入的每一块，我们要创建一个摘要。该摘要需要包含三个关键信息。第一条信息是该部分中最长的运行是什么。我们已经说过了。这很简单。但它还需要识别在左边界上有什么。
of this section. What is the character at the left-most boundary? And how many times is that repeated? So let's say that the um, let's say that the start, like we said, thread zero is 10 elements. Let's say that the first two of those elements were zero. Well, then on the left side of thread zero's chunk, there is a run of two zeros. Um, and then let's maybe say at the end the end of that 10 element section, the last three
这个部分的左边界是什么字符？它重复了多少次？假设，就像我们说的，线程 0 有 10 个元素。假设前两个元素是 0。那么在线程 0 的块的左侧，有一个长度为 2 的 0 的运行。然后，假设在 10 个元素部分的末尾，最后 3 个
elements are ones. So on the right of thread zeros section, there's a run of three ones. And we need that information about what is the first run in each section and the last run in each section. Because when the thread with the next section, the next consecutive section, is looking for its longest run, it needs to ask its neighbor, right? Because it needs to check, hey, I've got a run at the start of my sequence.
元素是 1。那么在线程 0 部分的右侧，有一个长度为 3 的 1 的运行。我们需要关于每个部分的第一个运行和最后一个运行的信息。因为当下一个部分的线程，即下一个连续部分的线程，在寻找它的最长运行时，它需要询问它的邻居，对吧？因为它需要检查：“嘿，我的序列开头有一个运行。”
I have a run of, you know, four ones at the start of my sequence. And I need to know, is there a run of ones at the end of the elements that, you know, are right before my elements? And if there are, then I need to combine that run with this run because that might be the longest run. Does that still make sense? Yeah, it makes complete sense. So how do we get these summaries? Well, this summary is a data structure. The way that I structured this data structure is, you know, first I created a data structure called a run.
“我的序列开头有四个 1 的运行。我需要知道，在我元素之前的那些元素的末尾是否有 1 的运行？如果有，那么我需要把那个运行和这个运行结合起来，因为那可能是最长的运行。”这还有道理吗？是的，完全有道理。那么我们如何获得这些摘要呢？好吧，这个摘要是一个数据结构。我构建这个数据结构的方式是，首先我创建了一个名为“运行”（run）的数据结构。
And a run is just a value and a size. The way that I chose to solve this problem, I solved the more general case of counting the max consecutive number of elements of the same value and also recording what their value was. So a run is a value and a size. And then a summary consists of three runs. There's the first run in that section. There's the last run in that section. And then there's the longest run in that section. And then there's also a Boolean flag that I need to keep because there's a special case, and the special case is if the entire section was one element repeated the entire way through, I have to handle that a little bit specially. But that's not super important. Well, it's important to get it right, but it's not sort of critical to the algorithm. So our input is, you know, some value type. Let's just call it t.
一个运行只是一个值和一个大小。我选择解决这个问题的方式是，我解决了计算相同值的最大连续元素数量的更一般的情况，并记录了它们的值。所以一个运行就是一个值和一个大小。然后一个摘要由三个运行组成。该部分中的第一个运行，该部分中的最后一个运行，以及该部分中的最长运行。还有一个我需要保留的布尔标志，因为有一个特殊情况，特殊情况是如果整个部分都是同一个元素重复，我必须稍微特殊处理一下。但这不是很重要。好吧，把它做对很重要，但它对算法来说不是关键。所以我们的输入是某种值类型。我们称之为 T。
So when we take two t's and we feed them into our reduction operator, that's how we generate the first set of summaries. When we reduce two elements, we can create a summary that describes those two elements. Now, likewise, if we have a reduction over one of these summaries in one element, we can also combine that into a summary. Because, you know, if you think about it, if we have just one element in isolation, it's pretty easy to construct a summary to it. If we just have one element, well, the first run in one element is the element itself, and its length is one. The last run for one element is the element itself, and its length is one. And the longest run is one element is the element itself and its length is one. And the longest run is the element itself and its length is one. And so, likewise, you know, in the more general case when we have two different, when we have a summary on the left side of the reduction
所以当我们取两个 T 并把它们输入到我们的归约算子中时，这就是我们生成第一组摘要的方式。当我们归约两个元素时，我们可以创建一个描述这两个元素的摘要。同样，如果我们对这些摘要中的一个进行归约，我们也可以把它组合成一个摘要。因为，如果你想一想，如果我们只有一个孤立的元素，构造一个摘要是很容易的。如果我们只有一个元素，那么一个元素中的第一个运行就是元素本身，长度为 1。一个元素的最后一个运行就是元素本身，长度为 1。最长运行也是元素本身，长度为 1。所以，同样地，在更一般的情况下，当我们有两个不同的，当我们归约的左侧有一个摘要，
and a summary on the right side of the reduction, you know, we can combine those two and produce a summary that describes the entire region. But for all of this to work, we need a guarantee. And the guarantee is that the left-hand side of the reduction has to contain information for a set of elements that are before and consecutive with the right hand side. So let's go back to the case of just two elements. So our reduction operator needs the guarantee that if you call it on two elements of the input sequence, you're calling it on two elements of this input sequence that are right next to each other, that are consecutive, and that there's no elements in between them.
右侧有一个摘要时，我们可以结合这两个摘要，产生一个描述整个区域的摘要。但要使这一切工作，我们需要一个保证。这个保证是，归约的左侧必须包含在右侧之前且连续的一组元素的信息。所以让我们回到只有两个元素的情况。所以我们的归约算子需要一个保证：如果你在输入序列的两个元素上调用它，你是在输入序列中彼此相邻、连续的两个元素上调用它，并且它们之间没有其他元素。
And then that produces a summary. And if you reduce two summaries, you need the guarantee that, hey, these are summaries for two regions of elements that are right next to each other. So what do we call this requirement? Well, specifically what we're asking for is we want a reduction that will not commute the input elements. So commutativity is the property of an operation that says, you know, A plus B equals is the same thing as saying B plus A. But in our case, that doesn't work for this algorithm. We need a reduction that promises that it won't reorder the inputs in that way.
然后这会产生一个摘要。如果你归约两个摘要，你需要保证：嘿，这些是彼此相邻的两个元素区域的摘要。那么我们称这个要求为什么呢？好吧，具体来说，我们要求的是一个不会交换输入元素的归约。所以交换律是一个操作的属性，它说 A 加 B 等于 B 加 A。但在我们的例子中，这个算法行不通。我们需要一个归约，它承诺不会以那种方式重新排序输入。
So does C++ have that today? Well, there's std accumulate. Std accumulate promises that it won't reorder the inputs. But std accumulate actually makes even stronger guarantees than that. It promises that it will associate the operations in a very specific order. And the order that it prescribes completely prevents parallelism, which kind of defeats the whole point of what we're trying to do. We want a parallel max consecutive ones. So accumulate will work for non-commutative and non-associative operations. And what we have here is we have an operation that is non-commutative, but it is associative. Okay, so there is another option, which we added in C++17.
那么 C++ 今天有这个吗？好吧，有 std::accumulate。Std::accumulate 承诺它不会重新排序输入。但 std::accumulate 实际上做出了比这更强的保证。它承诺它将以非常特定的顺序关联操作。而它规定的顺序完全阻止了并行性，这在某种程度上违背了我们想要做的全部目的。我们想要一个并行的“最大连续 1”。所以 accumulate 适用于非交换和非结合操作。而我们这里有一个非交换但结合的操作。好吧，所以还有另一个选择，我们在 C++17 中添加了它。
It's called stood reduce. Stood reduce is like the opposite end of the spectrum from std accumulate. Std reduce is allowed to arbitrarily reorder the inputs, and it's allowed to perform the operations in whatever order it wants. It's allowed to associate the operations in any way that it wants. So std reduce only supports things that are both commutative and associative. But the benefit of it is that it can be paralyzed. But this presents a problem for us because std reduce, like, again, as I said, we have an operation here that is associative but not commutative. And we want to do a parallel reduction on it.
它叫 std::reduce。Std::reduce 就像是 std::accumulate 的另一端。Std::reduce 被允许任意重新排序输入，并且被允许以它想要的任何顺序执行操作。它被允许以它想要的任何方式关联操作。所以 std::reduce 只支持既满足交换律又满足结合律的操作。但它的好处是它可以被并行化。但这给我们带来了一个问题，因为 std::reduce，正如我所说，我们这里的操作是结合的但不是交换的。我们想对它进行并行归约。
And we simply don't have that primitive in C++ today or in thrust today. In our previous recordings, I hypothesized that thrust's reduction might actually make this guaranteed. That thrust's reduction might actually not commute the inputs. And so it might actually work for this, even though it's not documented that way. But one of my colleagues later pointed out, no, it actually does in some cases reorder the inputs. Because oftentimes when you're computing things on GPUs, you want to sort of swizzle or transpose the input elements. Or instead of doing things exactly in order, you want to sort of do things by slices so that you get memory coalescing.
而我们今天在 C++ 或 Thrust 中根本没有那个原语。在我们之前的录音中，我假设 Thrust 的归约可能实际上保证了这一点。Thrust 的归约可能实际上不会交换输入。所以它可能实际上有效，即使它没有被记录为那样。但我的一个同事后来指出，不，它在某些情况下确实会重新排序输入。因为通常当你计算 GPU 上的东西时，你想要对输入元素进行重排或转置。或者与其完全按顺序做，你想要按切片做，这样你就能获得内存合并。
Now, the interesting thing is we don't have any reduction operation that does this. But there's another class of algorithms called scans. A reduction gives you back a single result. A scan gives you back the partial sums. So it gives you back the result of accumulating, the result of the accumulation incrementally. Yes, incrementally yes incrementally so it gives you every increment and partial sum is that yeah partial sum is actually that's borrowing sort of from the c++ you know pre-c++11 algorithm name but arguably like that's that's a suboptimal name because the sum implies like you're sort of hard coding
现在，有趣的是我们没有任何归约操作能做到这一点。但还有另一类算法叫扫描（scan）。归约给你一个单一的结果。扫描给你部分和。所以它给你增量累加的结果。是的，增量，是的，增量，所以它给你每一个增量和部分和，是吗？是的，部分和实际上是借用了 C++（C++11 之前）的算法名称，但可以说那是一个次优的名称，因为“和”意味着你把默认二元操作“加”的语义硬编码到了算法名称中，这就是为什么“扫描”（scan）——也就是我们称之为 C++17 并行版本——更好，因为它即使可能没有唤起算法在做什么，你也可以使用部分和来做部分最大值、部分最小值或部分乘积。它基本上是一个归约，只是每一步你都在输出那一刻的增量结果。所以为了能够在你进行时输出那个增量结果，你不能交换输入，对吧？
the semantics of the default binary operation plus that comes with the algorithm into the algorithm name, which is why scan, which is what we call the C++17 parallel versions is better because it's, you know, even though it's not maybe evocative of what the algorithm is doing, it's, you know, you can use partial sum to do a partial max or a partial min or a partial product. It's basically a reduction that's just every step of the way you're outputting the incremental result at that point. So to be able to output that incremental result as you go, you can't commute the inputs, right?
（注：原文此处有重复，已按逻辑合并）
Because if you do, then you're going to produce the wrong partial results. you can't commute the inputs, right? Right, correct. Because if you do, then you're going to produce the wrong partial results. So these scan operations, these parallel scan operations, like std reduce, the C++ parallel scan operations, do not support non-associative operations, but they support non-commutative operations. And that's exactly what we need. We have a reduction operator that is non-commutative, but it is associative. So, you know, one option would be, you know, okay, well, I want to do a sum that's associative, but not commutative. I don't have a parallel way to do that with
因为如果你这样做，那么你就会产生错误的部分结果。所以这些扫描操作，这些并行扫描操作，像 std::reduce，C++ 并行扫描操作，不支持非结合操作，但它们支持非交换操作。而这正是我们所需要的。我们有一个非交换但结合的归约算子。所以，一个选择是，好吧，我想做一个结合但不是交换的加法。我没有并行的办法用 std::reduce 来做，所以我可以用扫描，对吧？事实上，我想自从我们遇到这个问题以来，我们已经了解到这就是我们的一些用户所做的。但这当然是低效的。如果你只需要最终的一个结果，你必须在某处写出所有的增量和，这是相当低效的。所以我认为我们发现和探索的结论，我们的旅程，通往这个算法的旅程——这就是我刚才想到的词，我们的旅程——是我们缺少一个算法。我们缺少一个支持非交换操作，
std reduce, so I could just use a scan, right? And in fact, I think we've learned since we came across this problem that that's what some of our users do. But this is, of course, inefficient. If you just need the one final result, it's quite inefficient that you have to write out all of the incremental sums somewhere. So I think the conclusion of our discovery and our exploration, our journey, our journey to this algorithm. That's the word I was thinking of, our journey. Is that we are missing an algorithm. We are missing a reduction that is, that supports non-commutative operations,
但要求操作是结合的归约。我们不能仅仅改变 std::reduce 来支持这一点，因为事实证明，在我们的实现中，在 Thrust 中，对于 GPU 以及其他一些实现中，我们利用了 std::reduce 给实现重新排序输入的自由，这实际上是一件有用的事情。所以不，我们需要的是一个新算法。我不知道我们叫它什么。你对叫它什么有什么想法吗？好吧，我们不是提到了吗？我们不能谈论会议的所有内容，但我们在本周早些时候在 NVIDIA 开了一个会，和一些 ISO 的人，Michael Garland 不是研究主管吗？
but requires that operations be associative. And we can't just change std reduce to support this because it turns out that in our implementation and in in thrust and for gpus and also in some other implementations we take advantage of the the freedom that std reduce gives implementations to reorder the inputs that's actually a useful thing so no what we what we need is we need a new algorithm i i don't know what we call it do you have any ideas on what we call it well we didn't we bring this up you know we can't talk about uh all the all the content of the meeting but we had a meeting earlier in the week at nvidia with um some iso folks and didn't michael garland who's the head of research
他说我们应该澄清一下 Michael Garland 和 Bill D，后者才是真正的研究主管。哦，我被解雇了吗？Michael Garland 是我们并行系统和算法研究组的主任。他不是所有 NVIDIA 研究的主任。我的错。这就是为什么 Bryce 在步步高升。我只是把这些东西打进键盘里。但是的，Michael 建议叫“结合归约”（Associative Reduce）。我想在尝试命名它之前先暂停一下——
said uh we should we should clarify for michael garland and bill d, who's the actual head of research. Oh, am I fired? Michael Garland is the director of our parallel systems and algorithms research group. He is not the director of all of the video research. My bad. This is why Bryce is climbing the ladder. I just typed this stuff into the keyboard. But yeah, Michael suggested Associate of Reduce. And I think even to pause before trying to name it is –
顺便说一句，这是一个糟糕的名字。你知道，Bryce 和我在这个播客上进行的归约网球比赛，这是一个里程碑式的，因为归约太重要了，太基础了。我的意思是，Ben Dean 有一个完整的演讲叫《探索算法帝国：std::accumulate》，他在其中展示了 C++ 算法标准库中 90 个算法中的 77 个都可以用归约来实现。我在第一次做算法直觉演讲时所做的评论之一是，std::accumulate 是一个糟糕的名字，引入 C++17 的 std::reduce 是一个更好的通用名称。事后看来，我认为把它作为一个座右铭或口号是一个错误，比如“引入 C++17 std::reduce，一个命名更好的 std::accumulate 版本”，因为它本质上不是 std::accumulate，std::reduce 是两个不同的算法。基本上这期节目——这可能会接近一个小时，因为我认为这很重要——是说，std::accumulate 在左边，它说：“我们什么都不要求。交换、非交换、结合、非结合，我们不在乎。我们会让它工作。”而 std::reduce 说：“慢着。你需要结合律和交换律。否则，不行。我们什么都不做。”
It's a terrible name, by the way. you know, reduction tennis match that Bryce and I have been having live on this podcast is that this has been like a monumental sort of, because reductions are, they're so important. They're so fundamental. I mean, Ben Dean has a whole talk called Stood Accumulate Exploring an Algorithmic Empire, where he shows that like 77 of the 90 of the algorithms that exist in the standard library of algorithms in C++ are implementable in terms of a reduction. And one of the remarks that I made the very first time I gave my algorithm intuition talk is that, you know, std accumulate, it's a bad name, introducing C++17's std reduce, which is a much better sort of generic name and in hindsight i think that's like a mistake to to like have that as sort of like a not a motto but like a slogan of like you
基本上我们在这里确定的是，哦，我们有一个问题。从技术上讲，我们可以用扫描来解决它，因为扫描不需要交换律。而我们这里有的就是这个。但我们不想要扫描。我们想要一个等效的归约，做完全相同的事情，只是不需要交换律。进入 Bryce 刚才说的，我们缺少这个算法。如果用户实际上在进行扫描，因为扫描的属性之一是
know introducing c++ 17 stood reduce a better named version of stood accumulate because it's not fundamentally stood accumulate and stood reduce are two different algorithms and basically what what this episode is, and this is probably going to end up going closer to an hour because I think it's important, is that we're, you know, a stood accumulates on the left and it says, we don't require anything. Commutative, non-commutative, associative, non-associative, we don't care. We'll make it work. And stood reduce says, hold your horses. You need both associative and commutative. Otherwise, no bueno. We're not doing anything.
扫描的最后一个元素总是等于等效的归约。如果人们只是在扫描然后取最后一个元素，那么基本上性能就被浪费了。因为归约，在我看来，它们太基础了，我认为我们绝对应该添加这个。这实际上不是第一次出现这种情况，我当时想：“哇，这很重要。”
And basically what we've identified here is, oh, we have a problem. Technically, we could solve it using a scan because scans don't require commutativity. And that's what we have here. But we don't want a scan. We want an equivalent reduction that does the exact same thing, but that just doesn't require that commutativity. And enter what Bryce just said is we're missing this algorithm. And if users actually are scanning, because that's one of the properties of a scan is
但这实际上在 Rapids 的会议上出现过，我工作的团队，人们指出：“哦，是的，如果我们只是有一个并行左折叠（parallel fold left），我们可以更高效地做到这一点。”但那是最后说的话。然后我们就继续前进了。因为，是的，看到你得出这个结论真是太有趣了，Connor。我告诉你为什么。因为当你我第一次见面时，
that the last element of a scan is always equal to the equivalent reduction. And if that's basically what people are doing is just scanning and then taking the last element, there's basically perf that's being left on the floor. And because reductions, in my opinion, they're so fundamental that I think that we should definitely be adding this. And it's not the first time actually, it's the first time this has come up where I've been like, wow, this is important.
你已经是算法向导了。我们之前讲过我们第一次见面时，你在湾区 C++ 用户组做关于算法直觉的演讲。之后，你和我聊天，我们聊到的至少有两件事：第一，我告诉了你“按键归约”（reduce by key），
But it's actually come up in meetings on Rapids, the team that I work on, where people have pointed out, oh yeah, if we just sort of had like a parallel fold left, we could do this a little bit more efficiently. But that was sort of the, you know, that was the last thing that was said. And then we just moved on. Because, yeah, you know, it's so it's so interesting to, to see you to have seen you reach that conclusion, Connor. And I'll tell you why. Because when you and I first met,
但我们也谈到，你曾建议 reduce 是一个比 accumulate 命名更好的版本。那是你第一次建议它的地方。我向你指出，在你的一些例子中，由于假设的原因，它不一定有效，比如你使用了一些异构归约，类似于我刚才描述的，其中归约算子产生不同的类型。比如我描述的那个“最大连续 1”算法，在那个算法中，
you were already an algorithms wizard. And we've told the story before of how we first met when you gave a talk at the Bay Area C++ user group on algorithm intuition. And afterwards, you and I chatted, and at least two of the things that we chatted about was one, I told you about reduce by key,
输入类型是 T，但归约算子返回摘要。然后，它也有接受摘要和 T 并归约摘要的重载，以及接受摘要和摘要的重载。但如果我没记错的话，在你做那个演讲时，在你来 NVIDIA 工作之前，你研究算法，但你并没有真正研究过并行算法。对吗？没错，是的。如何编写并行算法，以及你所处的默认模式，你已经开始欣赏这两者之间的微妙之处和区别，以及这些语义有多重要。这对我来说太迷人了，看到你达到了这一点。我认为这说明了一些非常基础的东西，
but we also talked about, you had suggested that reduce was a better named version of accumulate. That was the first place where you'd suggested it. And I pointed out to you that in some of your examples, that it didn't necessarily work because of the assumption of, you know, you were using some sort of heterogeneous reduction, similar to the one that I just described, where the reduction operator produces a different type. Like this max consecutive ones algorithm I described in that algorithm,
关于并行编程，那就是你需要一种完全不同的思维方式。你知道，当我思考一个问题，关于如何实现一个算法时，我不是最好的算法专家。我会自由地承认这一点。那不是我的专长或特长。如果你把 Connor 和我放在一个房间里，让我们解决一个算法，Connor 可能会比我做得更好。但我有一点经验。
the inputs types are Ts, but the reduction operator returns summaries. And then, you know, it also has overloads that take summaries and Ts and reduce summaries and overloads that take summaries and summaries. But correct me if I'm wrong before, like at that time, when you gave that talk, before you came to work at NVIDIA, you worked on algorithms, but you hadn't really worked on parallel algorithms. Is that right? Correct, yeah. how to write parallel algorithms and sort of like where the, that's the default mode that you're in, you know, you, you've, you've come to appreciate the, the subtlety and the distinction between those two and how important like these semantics are. Um, and it's just, it's just so, so fascinating to me to see you have reached that point. And I think it speaks to something that's really fundamental
输入类型是Ts，但归约运算符返回的是摘要。然后，你知道，它还有一些重载，可以接受摘要和Ts并归约摘要，还有一些重载可以接受摘要和摘要。但在我纠正你之前，比如在那个时候，当你做那次演讲时，在你来NVIDIA工作之前，你研究过算法，但你并没有真正研究过并行算法。对吗？没错，是的。如何编写并行算法，以及你所处的默认模式，你知道，你已经开始欣赏这两者之间的微妙之处和区别，以及这些语义有多重要。嗯，看到你达到这一点，我真的觉得非常非常着迷。我认为这说明了一些非常根本的东西
about parallel programming, which is you need this whole different mindset. You know, when I think about a problem, about how to implement an algorithm, I'm not the best algorithms person. I will freely admit that. That is not my expertise or specialty. If you put Connor and I in a room and ask us to solve an algorithm, Connor's going to probably do a better job of it than me. But I have a bit more experience
关于并行编程，那就是你需要一种完全不同的思维方式。你知道，当我思考一个问题，思考如何实现一个算法时，我并不是最擅长算法的人。我会坦率地承认这一点。那不是我的专长或特长。如果你把我和康纳放在一个房间里，让我们解决一个算法问题，康纳可能会比我做得更好。但我有更多的经验
with parallel programming than Connor. So if you put us in a room and you tell me, like my default reaction is going to be to try to solve the problem in parallel. That's just how I've wired myself to think. And, you know, one of the first tools that I reach for is, you know, is there a way that I can express this in terms of reduction? Or like what parallel primitive can I express this in? And actually, I think, Connor, that you and I have a joint talk in our future. reduction or like what parallel primitive can i express this in and actually i think i think
比 Connor 更擅长并行编程。所以如果你把我们关在一个房间里，告诉我（去解决问题），我的默认反应就是尝试并行解决它。这就是我大脑的思维方式。而且，你知道，我最先想到的工具之一就是，有没有办法用归约（reduction）来表达这个问题？或者我可以用什么并行原语来表达它？实际上，Connor，我觉得我们未来会有一次联合演讲。
connor that you and i have a joint talk in our future a joint talk i'm sure i'm sure there's at least one joint talk and i think that talk is going to be like how to write reduction algorithms because you're right they are so powerful and and one of my takeaways from this whole experience has been that um they're even more powerful than i had thought and to the to the degree that a large chunk of my job seems to be identifying how people can rewrite something as a reduction. Right. And that's the thing is that like, when I think about, you know, you're much more of a, you know, 10 year, 20 year thinker of what is the future of programming look like. But, you know, when I picture it in my head, you know, there's sort of two, as it stands, like sort of roots, you can go to writing some parallel program. You can write
Connor，我们未来会有一次联合演讲。我肯定至少会有一次联合演讲，而且我觉得那次演讲的主题会是关于如何编写归约算法，因为你是对的，它们太强大了。我从这次经历中得到的收获之一就是，它们比我预想的还要强大，以至于我工作中很大一部分似乎就是识别人们如何将某些东西重写为归约。没错，这就是重点。当你思考编程的未来时，你是一个思考 10 年、20 年后的思想家。但在我脑海中，目前编写并行程序似乎有两条路径。你可以编写
CUDA kernels, or you can write your program in terms of algorithms. And I think it's, at least for me, it's a lot easier to express or solve a problem in terms of algorithms that other people have written. And that might be just my functional programming or APL bias. Like I'm used to reaching for maps and reductions and partitions and different algorithms and piping them together. That's basically the thrust model. You know, you have a collection of algorithms, you find a way to compose your problem and select them, or you can go and write a custom CUDA kernel. And, you know, I think Leslie Lay posted once on Twitter, a Drake meme of when he's in that song where he's got like the no and the yes face. And, you know, he says
CUDA 内核，或者你可以用算法来编写程序。对我来说，用别人写好的算法来表达或解决问题要容易得多。这可能是我对函数式编程或 APL 的偏见。我习惯于使用映射（map）、归约（reduction）、分区（partition）以及各种不同的算法，并将它们串联起来。这基本上就是 Thrust 模型。你知道，你拥有一系列算法，找到一种方法来组合你的问题并选择它们，或者你可以去编写一个自定义的 CUDA 内核。而且，我想 Leslie Lay 曾经在 Twitter 上发过一个 Drake 的梗图，就是他在那首歌里，有“不”和“是”的表情。他说
custom kernel, custom CUDA kernels, no thrust algorithms like yes, please, or whatever. And don't get me wrong, there's a time and a place in Rapids when we need a CUDA kernel for, you know, optimal efficiency, or we can't express something in terms of thrust algorithms, they're our go-to tool. We do that. We're currently working on a PR right now that is doing that. But I think for a large percentage of problems, they can be easily expressed in terms of whether it's a reduction
自定义内核，自定义 CUDA 内核，不；Thrust 算法，是的，请，或者类似的东西。别误会，在 Rapids 中，当我们为了最佳效率需要 CUDA 内核，或者无法用 Thrust 算法表达某些东西时，它们就是我们的首选工具。我们会那样做。我们目前正在处理一个 PR，就是在做这件事。但我认为对于很大一部分问题，它们可以很容易地用归约来表达，
or an algorithm that's in thrust or cub. And I think that's going to be way easier., you know, you use the sort of the on-ramp analogy all the time. It's a way easier on-ramp to go from, oh, I know how to do std colon colon insert algorithm to thrust colon colon algorithm. And, you know, seeing that, like, it's made me appreciate, you know, you mentioned, oh, in my talk, I had sort of examples. I can pinpoint one of them and it was implementing count if in terms of a stood reduce. And that doesn't work because basically your accumulator is going to be some size T or some int 32, which is keeping track of how many. And then your element that you're currently looking at could be anything.
或者用 Thrust 或 CUB 中的算法。我认为这会容易得多。你总是用“匝道”这个类比。从“我知道如何做 std::insert 算法”到“Thrust::algorithm”是一个更容易的切入点。看到这一点，让我很感激。你提到了我在演讲中有一些例子。我可以指出其中一个，那就是用 std::reduce 来实现 count_if。这行不通，因为基本上你的累加器会是一个 size_t 或 int32，用来记录数量。然后你当前正在查看的元素可能是任何东西。
It's just a value type. And so what if you're counting the number of 42s that show up in a list of numbers? Well, due to the fact that you're using a std reduce, usually in accumulate, your accumulator is on the left. So that's your running sum of how many times we've seen this. And then your value of whether that's a 42 or a non-42 number is going to be your right element in your binary operation. But std reduce, it could swap those around.
它只是一个值类型。那么，如果你要计算一个数字列表中 42 出现的次数呢？好吧，由于你使用的是 std::reduce，通常在 accumulate 中，你的累加器在左边。所以那是我们看到这个数字的运行总和。然后，无论它是 42 还是非 42 数字，你的值都将是二元运算中的右侧元素。但 std::reduce 可能会把它们调换过来。
And then accidentally, instead of doing a plus one, because you've encountered a 42, you actually added 42 to your running sum. So it completely breaks. And I think I had an idea at the time that I was writing this code and it didn't work. But I was just like, yeah, but I just like std reduce. It's just a better name. And so I don't want to type std accumulate on, yeah, but I just like std reduce. It's just a better name. And so I don't want to type std accumulate on my slide where I want to type std reduce. And that was, I think it's an okay mistake to make at that time.
然后不小心，你本该因为遇到 42 而加 1，结果却把 42 加到了你的运行总和中。所以它完全崩溃了。我想我在写这段代码时有一个想法，但它没起作用。我当时只是想，是的，但我就是喜欢 std::reduce。它只是一个更好的名字。所以我不想在幻灯片上输入 std::accumulate，我想输入 std::reduce。我认为在当时犯这个错误是可以接受的。
But in hindsight, I definitely, I'm sad that I did this. I wonder whether you could do that count if implementation with the missing reduce algorithm you can do it with the missing reduce aka associative reduce or find the better name but there's already an existing algorithm that you can solve that problem with oh play along we're playing that we're playing the play along game where bryce guesses the algorithm and if can't think about how much it would have thrust. See, I would have assumed that it was a reduce. So if you're an APL programmer listening to this problem,
但事后看来，我真的很遗憾我这么做了。我想知道你是否可以用缺失的归约算法来做那个 count_if 的实现，你可以用缺失的归约，也就是结合归约（associative reduce），或者找到更好的名字，但已经有一个现有的算法可以解决这个问题了。哦，一起玩吧，我们在玩那个猜谜游戏，Bryce 猜算法，如果他能想到 Thrust 里有多少。看，我本来会假设它是 reduce。所以如果你是一个正在听这个问题的 APL 程序员，
so here's the problem. We're implementing COUNTIF, which is an algorithm that, given a list of numbers or a list of values, but we'll simplify it. We just assume we have a list of numbers. It returns you the number of times that number shows up. So assume you've got the list 1, 2, 3, 42, 4, 5, 6, 42, and you're searching for 42. Count if will return you 2. And if you're an APL programmer or a J programmer or an array-oriented thinker,
问题是这样的：我们正在实现 COUNTIF，这是一个算法，给定一个数字列表或值列表，我们简化一下，假设我们有一个数字列表。它返回该数字出现的次数。假设你有列表 1, 2, 3, 42, 4, 5, 6, 42，你在搜索 42。Count if 会返回 2。如果你是一个 APL 程序员、J 程序员或面向数组的思考者，
you've already solved this problem in your head, guaranteed. And this is exciting. So in Thrust, we implement it as a transform reduce. Woo, there we go. That's a ding, ding, ding, which is awesome because this is exactly how you solve it in APL. So in APL, what you would do is you'd go 42 equals your list
你已经在脑海中解决了这个问题，保证。这太令人兴奋了。所以在 Thrust 中，我们把它实现为 transform_reduce。呜，就是这样，叮叮叮，这太棒了，因为这正是你在 APL 中解决它的方式。所以在 APL 中，你会做 42 等于你的列表，
and that's going to turn it into a Boolean array of ones and zeros. So it'll be 00001, 00001, and then you just do a plus reduction. And in C++ or Thrust, you're just going to do the exact same thing with the transform reduce. Note that this is the transform reduce that just has a single range, so it applies a unary operation to transform the integers into ones and zeros or trues and falses, and then you do a plus reduction. is this is very similar to one of my favorite examples the parallel word count one where which you implement with transform
这会把它变成一个由 1 和 0 组成的布尔数组。所以它会是 00001, 00001，然后你只需要做一个加法归约。在 C++ 或 Thrust 中，你只需要用 transform_reduce 做同样的事情。注意，这是一个只有一个范围的 transform_reduce，所以它应用一个一元操作将整数转换为 1 和 0 或真和假，然后你做一个加法归约。这和我最喜欢的例子之一非常相似，即并行单词计数，你用 transform
reduce with a with a binary right right and the idea that we i'm sure we've talked about it before but the idea there is that as a transformation you you you take you do a binary transform where it takes two inputs. And what you do is you look at the left element, like two consecutive elements at a time, and you return whether that's the end of a word. And you do that by checking is the character on the left a non-space and the character on the right is a space? Okay, then it's an end of the word.
reduce 和一个二元运算来实现。对，对，我们肯定之前讨论过这个想法，但这里的想法是，作为一种转换，你执行一个二元转换，它接受两个输入。你所做的是查看左边的元素，一次两个连续的元素，然后返回这是否是一个单词的结尾。你通过检查左边的字符是否是非空格，右边的字符是否是空格来做到这一点？好的，那它就是一个单词的结尾。
And so then that produces an intermediate sequence of ones and zeros where each one represents the end is a space, okay, then it's an end of the word. And so then that produces an intermediate sequence of ones and zeros where each one represents the end of a word. And then you just reduce that. And it's so elegant. Right. And that algorithm that I think, yeah, we've explained, you've explained that before, the transform reduce that takes two ranges that are just using the zip tail trick. That could be an algorithm. And I actually presented it in the same algorithm intuition talk, not like a parallel version, but it's easily parallelizable with the implementation you explain, where it's called adjacent reduce.
所以这产生了一个由 1 和 0 组成的中间序列，其中每个 1 代表一个单词的结尾。然后你只需要归约它。这太优雅了。没错。那个算法，我想，是的，我们解释过，你之前解释过，那个使用 zip tail 技巧的 transform_reduce，它接受两个范围。那可能是一个算法。我实际上在同一个算法直觉演讲中展示过它，不是并行版本，但它很容易用你解释的实现进行并行化，它被称为 adjacent_reduce。
So basically exactly similar to adjacent difference or what should have been named adjacent transform or adjacent find, where you're looking at adjacent elements. And then at the end of the day for this, we're just doing a reduction and doing basically a plus one whenever we see a character and then a space because that denotes the end of a word.
所以基本上和 adjacent_difference 非常相似，或者应该被命名为 adjacent_transform 或 adjacent_find，你在查看相邻元素。最后，对于这个，我们只是在做一个归约，每当我们看到一个字符后面跟着一个空格时，基本上就加 1，因为这表示一个单词的结尾。
Yeah, that's a great algorithm that shows up all the time. The thing that makes reductions so powerful is that it is a way to pass global information efficiently. Like, I want to do something that requires me to know something about all the elements in this sequence, you know, that requires all of them to in some way to communicate. And a reduction is a super efficient way of doing that communication because that communication builds up over time.
是的，这是一个经常出现的伟大算法。使归约如此强大的原因是，它是一种有效传递全局信息的方法。比如，我想做一些需要了解序列中所有元素信息的事情，你知道，这需要它们以某种方式进行通信。而归约是一种非常有效的通信方式，因为这种通信是随着时间积累起来的。
Like one of the things that in my previous job when I worked in HPX, one of our fundamental tenets was to always localize communication. And Reduce really, really, really localizes communication because it ends up localizing it down to two, you know, actors at once. And, you know, on sort of the, you know, one of the points you made earlier about, you know, how much more powerful language like APL can be for parallel programming than writing things by hand. I think you're really right about that. And I think that there's still a revolution to come there. You know, there's a lot of interesting research these days and a lot of interesting
就像我在上一份工作在 HPX 工作时，我们的基本原则之一是始终本地化通信。而 Reduce 确实非常、非常、非常本地化了通信，因为它最终将其本地化为一次两个参与者。而且，关于你之前提到的关于 APL 这样的语言在并行编程方面比手动编写代码强大得多的观点，我觉得你是对的。我认为那里还有一场革命即将到来。你知道，最近有很多有趣的研究，
things that have been put into production around these machine learning graph compilers. They're these compilers where the underlying IR, the underlying operations that are supported, are all fundamentally parallel operations. Now, they're parallel operations that are sort of specific to the domain of machine learning but i think that that sort of technology is applicable to just general you know sequence algorithms so if you if you imagine a imagine an assembly language where every one of your operations is not operate on scalar data but operates on sequences of elements and where it's all parallel and um i i the one of the nice things about this model where you express your code in terms of some
围绕这些机器学习图编译器投入生产的东西。它们是编译器，底层的 IR，支持的底层操作，本质上都是并行操作。现在，它们是特定于机器学习领域的并行操作，但我认为这种技术适用于通用的序列算法。所以如果你想象一种汇编语言，其中你的每一个操作不是对标量数据进行操作，而是对元素序列进行操作，并且一切都是并行的。而且，这种模型的一个好处是，你用一些
known algorithms some known corpus of algorithms that is in in comparison to accelerating arbitrary code, accelerating a collection of calls to known algorithms is way easier. Because all you have to do is you have to implement those known algorithms efficiently. And especially, you know, it makes it easier to build specialized hardware, specialized accelerators, which is increasingly important in our post-Mort era. So I think that there is another revolution of functional programming languages that's yet to come. You know, the parallel APLs of the future. Who knows? Maybe you'll make one. Maybe it'll be you. Oh, Bryce, Bryce you're just you've done this so that you can say I remember back on episode 25 when I planted that seed and I've already been thinking about this for like since I've fallen in love with APL when you started working at NVIDIA do
已知的算法库来表达你的代码，与加速任意代码相比，加速对已知算法的调用要容易得多。因为你所要做的就是高效地实现这些已知算法。特别是，这使得构建专用硬件、专用加速器变得更容易，这在我们后摩尔时代越来越重要。所以我认为函数式编程语言还有另一场革命尚未到来。你知道，未来的并行 APL。谁知道呢？也许你会创造一个。也许会是你。哦，Bryce，Bryce，你做这些就是为了能说“我记得在第 25 集时我埋下了那颗种子”，而且自从你在 NVIDIA 开始工作后，我就一直在想这个问题。
you remember what I told you you were gonna do I told you you were going to build for me the next parallel programming language that actually if we're going to be technical technical about it that was even before i started at nvidia that was that was before you knew that you'd started it in video yeah i think technically what happened is i i had left my job at Amazon in like mid-September of 2019. Yeah, that sounds right. And then CppCon was like in the third week of September. And I want to say I actually like signed my offer. No, I did sign it when I was in Vancouver, which I can't even remember. That was the week after CppCon. But I remember distinctly being at CppCon in like the gathering welcome room.
你还记得我告诉过你你会做什么吗？我告诉过你你会为我构建下一个并行编程语言。实际上，如果我们从技术上讲，那甚至在我开始在 NVIDIA 工作之前。那是在你知道你会在 NVIDIA 开始工作之前。是的，我想技术上发生的事情是，我在 2019 年 9 月中旬左右离开了亚马逊的工作。是的，听起来没错。然后 CppCon 大约在 9 月的第三周。我想说我实际上签了我的录用信。不，我是在温哥华时签的，我甚至记不清了。那是 CppCon 之后的一周。但我清楚地记得在 CppCon 的聚会欢迎室里。
Or I don't even know. It was like it's the main area of that like lodge. And then we were sitting on the couch. And there was a couple people around. And you were like, all right, here's our codename project. You already had come up with a codename for a project that didn't exist yet. And yeah, it's an exciting space. Graph compilers right now, sort of they only exist in these, you know,
或者我甚至不知道。就像那个小屋的主要区域。然后我们坐在沙发上。周围有几个人。你说，“好吧，这是我们的代号项目。”你已经为一个还不存在的项目想出了一个代号。是的，这是一个令人兴奋的领域。图编译器现在，它们只存在于这些，你知道，
machine learning applications, but I don't know much about them, but it definitely seems like there's a use case for like a more generalized graph compiler that it's not just, you know, linear algebra that's sitting on top of it. It's just, it's a language. And yes, it's going to be a constrained language, but that's basically what the APL family of languages are. And honestly, like when you, I'm not, I've probably mentioned this before, but if you look at the popularity of, uh, the most popular Python libraries, like what's the number one Python library? It's NumPy. And NumPy is basically just a variant of APL.
机器学习应用中，但我对它们了解不多，但肯定看起来有一个更通用的图编译器的用例，它不仅仅是坐在它上面的线性代数。它就是一种语言。是的，它将是一种受限语言，但这基本上就是 APL 家族语言的样子。老实说，当你，我可能之前提到过，但如果你看看最流行的 Python 库的流行程度，比如排名第一的 Python 库是什么？是 NumPy。而 NumPy 基本上只是 APL 的一个变体。
Half of the functions in NumPy get their names directly from APL. Reshape, Shape, I don't know all of them, but it's basically, there's articles that have been written that talk about how NumPy is a ghost of Iverson, who is the individual who created the language. Anyways, I want to circle back to, you asked me, what should this, we're going full circle to like 30 minutes ago, when you asked, what should the name of this missing algorithm uh this and i'll and i'll tell you why i think associative reduce is a bad name because one um uh associative the fact that it's for operations that are associative is not the
NumPy 中一半的函数直接从 APL 获得名称。Reshape, Shape，我不知道所有的，但基本上，已经有文章写过关于 NumPy 如何是 Iverson 的幽灵，他是创造该语言的人。无论如何，我想回到你问我的问题，我们绕了一大圈回到 30 分钟前，你问，这个缺失的算法应该叫什么名字。我会告诉你为什么我认为 associative reduce 是一个糟糕的名字，因为第一，它是为结合律运算而设计的，这并不是
important part the important thing is that it does not commute yeah it doesn't require commutativity yeah now but non-commutative reduce be a bad name too because i think it's the more common case than reduce so and i guess maybe a question too is if if we could you know what should we name this missing algorithm and on top of that if we could name stood accumulate stood reduce and this lost algorithm you know carte blanche if that's if that's the correct way to say that. Oh, and also, I'm going to just interject here. I meant to say this earlier, and if I don't say it now, I'll forget. There were two people on Twitter that I actually, I believe, came to the solution that we explained.
重要的部分，重要的是它不满足交换律。是的，它不需要交换律。现在，非交换归约（non-commutative reduce）也是一个糟糕的名字，因为我认为它比 reduce 更常见。所以我想也许还有一个问题是，如果我们能，你知道，我们应该给这个缺失的算法起什么名字？最重要的是，如果我们能给 std::accumulate、std::reduce 和这个丢失的算法起名，拥有完全的自主权。哦，还有，我要在这里插一句。我本来想早点说这个，如果我现在不说，我就会忘记。Twitter 上有两个人，我相信，得出了我们解释的那个解决方案。
So Jean-Marc, I'm going to mispronounce your last name. I apologize. Bourget, it's B-O-U-R-g-u-e-t um i apologize and then also toby isaac i believe um both have a solution with this sort of summary object that's got four pieces of information you know the ones at the left the right and the max um so we weren't. Well, and we have to thank Tony Lewis, who if Tony had not mentioned this at the end of our of our Zoom call, I would have totally forgotten. And we know this episode never would have happened. So thank you. Yeah, thank you, Tony.
所以 Jean-Marc，我会把你的姓氏读错。我很抱歉。Bourget，是 B-O-U-R-g-u-e-t，我很抱歉，还有 Toby Isaac，我相信，他们都有一个解决方案，包含这种带有四条信息的摘要对象，你知道，左边的、右边的和最大值，所以我们不是。好吧，我们必须感谢 Tony Lewis，如果 Tony 没有在我们的 Zoom 通话结束时提到这一点，我肯定会完全忘记。我们知道这一集永远不会发生。所以谢谢你。是的，谢谢你，Tony。
This is and it's I think it's a really important. I hope, folks, this is definitely going to be one of our longer episodes. But especially if I include the stuff about my sock drawer at the beginning. So what do we call these? What do you think you'd name it? Well, there's Fold. But C++23 ranges are going to probably use Fold for something. I just finished telling Barry Revzin earlier a couple hours ago because he was asking me on the naming of uh the proposed c++23
这是，而且我认为这是一个非常重要的。我希望，伙计们，这绝对会是我们较长的一集之一。但特别是如果我把开头关于我袜子抽屉的内容包括进去的话。那么我们叫它们什么呢？你觉得你会给它起什么名字？嗯，有 Fold。但 C++23 ranges 可能要用 Fold 做别的事情。我几个小时前刚告诉 Barry Revzin，因为他问我关于提议的 C++23
reduction algorithm and i said i think i'm gonna write a paper just like purely on the namings naming a full because we already have stood accumulate and reduce and i don't think we're gonna how do you how do you feel about the fold like barry wants fold with initial value to have a different name than just fold and i want the python thing where they're they have the same name they're just overloads i honestly like i i don't know how i feel because i've looked at too many languages and like have forgotten you know i know haskell does like fold fold l fold r and then fold l1 and fold r1 uh barry just linked me uh apparently rust used to call it fold first and now they're they just finished renaming fold first
归约算法的命名，我说我想我会写一篇论文，纯粹是关于 Fold 的命名，因为我们已经有了 std::accumulate 和 reduce，我不认为我们会……你觉得 Fold 怎么样？Barry 想要带初始值的 fold 有一个不同于 fold 的名字，而我想要 Python 那种方式，它们名字相同，只是重载。老实说，我不知道我的感觉如何，因为我看过太多的语言，而且忘记了，你知道，我知道 Haskell 有 foldl、foldr，然后是 foldl1 和 foldr1。Barry 刚发给我，显然 Rust 过去称它为 fold_first，现在他们刚刚重命名了 fold_first，
um which i believe is the one without the initial value to reduce and i think that's what wait wait whoa whoa how can fold first be the one without the initial value like i completely misunderstood those names because i assume fold first was the one with the initial value let's open uh let's open slack so i don't get this wrong i I told Barry to talk to you too, by the way. I don't know if I CC you in that email, but my, so key management and leadership tip for people, quickly learn how to hand off emails and tasks whenever possible to someone else, even if that person doesn't technically work for you.
我相信这是那个没有初始值的，我认为这就是……等等，等等，哇，哇，fold_first 怎么可能是没有初始值的那个？我完全误解了这些名字，因为我以为 fold_first 是带初始值的那个。让我们打开 Slack，这样我就不会弄错了。顺便说一句，我告诉 Barry 也和你谈谈。我不知道我是否在那封邮件中抄送了你，但我的，所以给人们的关键管理和领导技巧，尽快学习如何尽可能地将电子邮件和任务移交给别人，即使那个人在技术上不为你工作。
Well, you gotta give me some name ideas for this new algorithm because I am going to go make somebody implement this in Thrust. Actually, there's a chance that the person who's going to be implementing this, who is starting at NVIDIA soon, is listening to this right now and is wondering, when he says, I'm going to make somebody go do that, does he mean me? The answer is yes. If you're starting at NVIDIA on my team in like two weeks, this will probably be a task that you'll do. So I still don't, because I need to read the details and I will go and fix this in post. But one of the alternatives for fold first
好吧，你得给我一些这个新算法的名字建议，因为我要去让某人实现这个 Thrust。实际上，很有可能那个即将实现这个功能的人，他很快就要在 NVIDIA 开始工作了，他现在正在听这个，并且在想，当他说“我要让某人去做那个”时，他指的是我吗？答案是肯定的。如果你在两周内开始在 NVIDIA 我的团队工作，这可能就是你会做的任务。所以我仍然不知道，因为我需要阅读细节，我会在后期去修复它。但是 fold_first 的替代方案之一
that was being suggested was try fold first, which almost definitely makes me think that it is the one that doesn't take an initial value because the try implies that you might fail. And the way you fail is if you have an empty list. So I'm almost positive that like fold first is the one that means just use the initial, use the first element of the list as your initial value. And so yeah, Haskell has fold L and fold R and those ones take initial values. And so yeah, Haskell has fold L and fold R, and those ones take initial values, and then they have fold L1 and fold R1, which don't take initial values. A lot of languages, they just choose two different algorithm names, like fold and reduce, and you just need to know, oh, the reduce is the one that doesn't take an initial value. I think that's what basically
被建议的是 try_fold_first，这几乎肯定让我认为它是那个不带初始值的，因为 try 暗示你可能会失败。而你失败的方式是如果你有一个空列表。所以我几乎可以肯定 fold_first 的意思是只使用列表的第一个元素作为你的初始值。所以是的，Haskell 有 foldl 和 foldr，那些带初始值。然后他们有 foldl1 和 foldr1，它们不带初始值。很多语言，它们只是选择两个不同的算法名称，比如 fold 和 reduce，你只需要知道，哦，reduce 是那个不带初始值的。我认为这就是基本上
ended up happening to Rust. And I don't know, what I'm going to do is I'm going to go and look at every single language. And that's the thing is on top of like initial values or not initial values, there's these associativity and commutativity requirements. Yeah, it would be really interesting to see a survey of what other languages call these and whether the associativity and commutativity is uh is is respected in in the various names of those things so yeah go make me one of your pretty tables it'll be yeah it'll be in the form of a paper maybe i'll make a youtube video as well um honestly i think that i think that if if not for the fact that that we were going to use the name fold for the ranges version of accumulate
最终发生在 Rust 身上的事情。我不知道，我要做的是去查看每一种语言。这就是重点，除了初始值或没有初始值之外，还有这些结合律和交换律的要求。是的，看看其他语言称呼这些东西，以及结合律和交换律是否在这些东西的各种名称中得到尊重，会非常有趣。所以是的，去给我做一个漂亮的表格，它会是，是的，它会以论文的形式出现，也许我也会做一个 YouTube 视频。老实说，我认为，如果不是因为我们要为 ranges 版本的 accumulate 使用 fold 这个名字，
i would probably use the name the name fold for this um i i feel like if i were doing this from scratch um i don't know there's a part of me that actually wants like uh the requirements of associativity and commutativity to be represented by the word like par par underscore um or like put that in a namespace so that like the parallel algorithms could have been like stood colon colon par colon colon um and then we could have just used the same names um arguably uh it's actually interesting if you look at um libstd c++ is implementation of std reduce not the parallel version one but just the regular one you'll see that even if you're not worried about parallelism the reduce like like they have a more efficient implementation because um uh they don't have to you know they don't have to avoid commuting and they can just associate the
我可能会为这个使用 fold 这个名字。我觉得如果我是从零开始做这件事，我不知道，我内心的一部分实际上想要像结合律和交换律的要求由像 par_ 这样的词来表示，或者把它放在一个命名空间里，这样并行算法就可以像 std::par::，然后我们就可以使用相同的名字。可以说，如果你看看 libstdc++ 对 std::reduce 的实现，不是并行版本，只是常规版本，你会发现即使你不担心并行性，reduce，就像他们有一个更高效的实现，因为他们不必避免交换，他们可以随意结合
operations however they want so it's not necessarily inherent to parallelism so yeah I feel like there's like a space though for like just the calling the accumulate fold left and then having a fold right version just for symmetry and then um having like parallel fold left and parallel fold right and then having like parallel fold and you're not explicitly pointing out that like oh the parallel fold left doesn't require uh that your operation be commutative but that's implied because i think it's actually what's what's more important is the behavior and honestly like until you at least for me, until I got hit over the head with like commutativity and associativity, like four
操作，所以它不一定与并行性固有相关。所以是的，我觉得有一个空间，比如只是把 accumulate 称为 fold_left，然后有一个 fold_right 版本以保持对称，然后有 parallel_fold_left 和 parallel_fold_right，然后有 parallel_fold，你没有明确指出“哦，parallel_fold_left 不需要你的操作是可交换的”，但这隐含了，因为我认为实际上更重要的是行为。老实说，直到我至少对我来说，直到我被结合律和交换律击中，像四次
different times, I could never remember which one was which. And actually, one of the things that helped is that in APL, there's an operator called commute, which basically swaps the order of arguments to a to argument function. So if you like, it's a very classical thing to do if you have a minus operation, or you're trying to do a minus reduction on something, and you need to swap it, well, instead of writing some custom lambda, or what they call a defun in APL, you just you apply the commute operator to the minus operation. And then with a single character, you swap the order. Subtraction is a great example of something that of an operator that does not support uh uh that's that's not associative that does not support you know be uh stood to reduce um uh now you could use it it's just the
不同的时间，我永远记不住哪个是哪个。实际上，有帮助的一件事是，在 APL 中，有一个运算符叫 commute，它基本上交换了双参数函数的参数顺序。所以如果你想，如果你有一个减法运算，或者你试图对某事做减法归约，你需要交换它，好吧，与其写一些自定义 lambda，或者他们在 APL 中称之为 defun 的东西，你只需将 commute 运算符应用于减法运算。然后用一个字符，你就交换了顺序。减法是一个很好的例子，它是一个不支持结合律的运算符，不支持 std::reduce。
like you know you might get unexpected results whereas addition you know and when i when i say subtraction i mean like subtraction on the set of natural numbers. Likewise, addition on the set of natural numbers is a good example of something that does support commutative. Sorry, I said associativity there. I meant commutativity for all of what I just said. Yeah. I know that in Q, which is array language, they have parallel versions of some of their functions, and they just prefix it with a P. So they have, like, each, which— I don't—I think that that's wrong, though.
现在你可以使用它，只是你可能会得到意想不到的结果，而加法，你知道，当我提到减法时，我指的是自然数集上的减法。同样，自然数集上的加法是一个很好的例子，它确实支持交换律。抱歉，我刚才说了结合律。我刚才说的所有内容我指的都是交换律。是的。我知道在 Q 中，这是一种数组语言，它们有一些函数的并行版本，它们只是在前面加一个 P。所以它们有，比如，each，这——我不——但我认为那是错的。
I think that these semantics are not about parallelism. So you don't like the fold left, parallel fold left, and parallel fold? No, I don't. I don't think it's about parallelism. I think it's about commutivity and associativity. But I think those are just words that are too long to put into the name. So what is your take on parallel and left implying that you don't need a commutative operation and parallel with fold or whatever not requiring or requiring both of them um like you're like so you're saying that really what's key is associativity and commutativity
我认为这些语义与并行性无关。所以你不喜欢 fold_left、parallel_fold_left 和 parallel_fold？不，我不喜欢。我不认为这与并行性有关。我认为这与交换律和结合律有关。但我认为这些词太长了，不能放在名字里。那么你对 parallel 和 left 暗示你不需要可交换操作，而 parallel 和 fold 或其他什么不要求或要求两者有什么看法？就像你在说，真正关键的是结合律和交换律，
but is there is there no way to name the algorithms that like doesn't make that explicit and overwhelm the user or should we just expect that in 20 years parallelism is going to be everywhere and it's just going to be the same way that learning what's to accumulate does and how important that algorithm is we're going to expect people to know what whatever the different variants of these parallel versions are so as i often say one of my goals is to normalize parallelism um uh and i i just think that the way that the algorithm is executed should be completely divorced from the the the semantics that it expresses like you should like i stood reduced and like this is why there is both a, when we had to introduce a new, like a std reduce because we couldn't parallelize std accumulate, we didn't just add a parallel version of it. We didn't just call it parallel accumulate.
但有没有办法命名这些算法，而不使它显式化并压倒用户？或者我们应该只是期待 20 年后并行性将无处不在，就像学习 std::accumulate 的作用以及该算法的重要性一样，我们将期待人们知道这些并行版本的不同变体是什么？正如我常说的，我的目标之一是规范化并行性。我只是认为算法的执行方式应该与它表达的语义完全脱钩。你应该，就像我喜欢 std::reduce，这就是为什么既有，当我们不得不引入一个新的 std::reduce 时，因为我们无法并行化 std::accumulate，我们没有仅仅添加一个并行版本。我们没有仅仅称它为 parallel_accumulate。
There is both a std reduce that takes an execution policy and one that doesn't. Right, right. And I think that that's absolutely essential that you separate parallelism from the semantics of the algorithm. Right, right. yeah i'll have to i'll have to think i have to think i'll have to write the paper and um my guess is that like one naming scheme that would probably be if if the if the naming scheme was like very clear like like uh you know maybe non-community of reduce isn't the worst in the world that's actually the name of if you you look in the wording for std reduce and for, and for the scan algorithms, we actually have these things called generalized sum and then generalized non-commutative sum. So maybe non-commutative, uh, reduce isn't the worst
既有一个接受执行策略的 std::reduce，也有一个不接受的。没错，没错。我认为将并行性与算法的语义分离开来是绝对必要的。没错，没错。是的，我得考虑一下，我得写那篇论文。我的猜测是，如果命名方案非常清晰，比如，你知道，也许 non-commutative reduce 并不是世界上最糟糕的名字。如果你查看 std::reduce 和 scan 算法的措辞，实际上我们有这些被称为广义和（generalized sum）和广义非交换和（generalized non-commutative sum）的东西。所以也许 non-commutative reduce 并不是世界上最糟糕的
name in the world. Again, I think that it's actually more useful than, than reduce. Um, uh, I'll boldly claim that. I mean, it's, is that even a bold claim? It's a less restricted algorithm. Of course, it's going to be. Should reduce, if you don't need the freedom, you may take a big performance hit for it. Right if you if your operator is commutative you may may take a big performance hit from from invoking the version of the algorithm that assumes that you can't commute that'd be actually i would i'd be interested to maybe i should go that's if i ever come out of retirement from speaking uh profiling this kind of stuff on a variety of problems it would be interesting to see what is the impact.
名字。再说一次，我认为它实际上比 reduce 更有用。我会大胆地声称这一点。我的意思是，这甚至是一个大胆的声明吗？它是一个限制较少的算法。当然会是这样。如果不需要自由度，你可能会为此付出巨大的性能代价。没错，如果你的运算符是可交换的，你可能会因为调用假设你不能交换的算法版本而付出巨大的性能代价。那实际上会很有趣，如果我从演讲中退休，在各种问题上分析这类东西，看看影响是什么，那会很有趣。
Yeah, to explain why we'd have to do a whole separate episode talking about memory coalescing. And, you know, we've talked a few times about how to get Olivier on this podcast to explain to people what GPUs are. And maybe that's the way to do it is that we tell him, hey, because the last time we talked to Olivier, he was like, that's such a big topic. You have to give me some parameters. And so maybe the parameters that we give him is we tell him, yeah, come on and explain memory coalescing.
是的，要解释为什么我们必须做一个单独的剧集来谈论内存合并（memory coalescing）。而且，你知道，我们已经讨论过几次如何让 Olivier 上这个播客向人们解释什么是 GPU。也许这就是方法，我们告诉他，嘿，因为上次我们和 Olivier 交谈时，他说，那是一个很大的话题。你必须给我一些参数。所以也许我们给他的参数是我们告诉他，是的，来解释一下内存合并。
Explain how the world of memory traffic is completely different on CPUs and GPUs in terms of what's optimal. Boy, this is just going to be a really difficult episode for you to cut. There's no clear middle point. We normally – I don't think I'm going to split this. I think I'm just going to release it all as one because – It deserves that. But the audience should understand that normally when Connor and I record,
解释一下内存流量的世界在 CPU 和 GPU 上在什么是最佳方面是完全不同的。天哪，这对你来说将是一个非常困难的剪辑剧集。没有明确的中间点。我们通常——我不认为我会拆分它。我想我只是会把它作为一个整体发布，因为它值得。但听众应该明白，通常当 Connor 和我录音时，
we record on Saturday mornings for me, Saturday afternoonsons for him normally we record for an hour and a half and that becomes like three episodes this is not that yeah we're at like what an hour and 15 minutes and i really want to include the sock stuff so it's just you're gonna be if you're if you've listened through i only got an hour and five i only got an hour and five minutes here in my on my recorder so my remember when we started this podcast how long did we say episodes were gonna be uh my goal was 30 minutes and then it became like an average of 35 and i was like that's perfect 35 minutes i thought that we said i thought that we said 20 oh yeah yeah actually that's true because yeah uh magic read-along is like roughly 20 it's like a long episode for them is like 30 minutes um that that was ever had an episode under 20
我们通常在周六早上录音，对他来说是周六下午。我们通常录一个半小时，那会变成三集。这不是那样。是的，我们现在大约一个小时 15 分钟，我真的很想把袜子的内容包括进去，所以你只是，如果你听完了，我只有一小时五分钟，我只有一小时五分钟在我的录音机上。所以记得当我们开始这个播客时，我们说剧集会有多长？我的目标是 30 分钟，然后它变成了平均 35 分钟，我想那太完美了，35 分钟。我以为我们说的是 20 分钟。哦，是的，是的，实际上那是真的，因为 magic read-along 大约是 20 分钟，对他们来说很长的一集大约是 30 分钟。那曾经有过低于 20 分钟的剧集吗？
under 20 minutes no i think our shortest ever was like 23 and that was because that was the episode on uh our impromptu episode on inclusive language that happened inception like because we ended up recording it in the midst of another episode. I'm sure if we had set out just to talk about that from the get-go, it would have ended up being 40 minutes easily. All right. Well, we should probably shut up before this becomes unbearably long. Anyways, we will put the god ball with the implementation of this algorithm.
低于 20 分钟？不，我想我们最短的一次大约是 23 分钟，那是因为那是关于我们关于包容性语言的即兴剧集，它发生在 inception，因为我们最终在另一集的中间录制了它。我相信如果我们从一开始就打算只谈论那个，它很容易就会变成 40 分钟。好吧。好吧，我们大概应该在它变得长得令人难以忍受之前闭嘴。无论如何，我们会把带有这个算法实现的 godbolt 链接放上去。
Now, I have done some verification that it's correct, but I do not know that I currently have any parallel implementation of this, of the reduction that I need to actually test this. So, but don't worry. I will soon have somebody put this into into thrust and then we'll be able to uh to play around with it yep thanks for thanks for staying tuned in this long or you know potentially we're talking to nobody and everybody turned us off at this point um that's also possible but this is this podcast really more for to make us feel good than to for the audience anyways.
现在，我已经做了一些验证，它是正确的，但我不知道我目前是否有任何这个归约的并行实现来实际测试它。所以，但别担心。我很快就会让某人把它放进 Thrust，然后我们就能够玩它了。是的，感谢你坚持听了这么久，或者你知道，可能我们是在对着空气说话，每个人都在这一点上关掉了我们，这也是可能的，但这个播客真的更多是为了让我们感觉良好，而不是为了听众。无论如何。
Right. Thanks for listening and have a great day. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
没错。感谢收听，祝你有美好的一天。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。